you this is the segment that I'm sure a
lot of people would have preferred us to
open up on
it's about Scandinavian Airlines so SAS
which I don't know what it stands for
but it's the Scandinavian Airlines ran a
commercial where they basically said
Scandinavian has no inherent culture
they said they were just as bad as the
Vikings and they even tried arguing
based off of a random cartoon squirrel
on Twitter I'm some I'm somewhat joking
there but a random Twitter user that
Swedish meatballs are not in fact
Swedish that's right which is not true
so I'm I'm actually part Swedish and I
grew up with a Swedish family and I I
had lots of Swedish meatballs my entire
life I I set a record in my family for
eating a hundred and eight of them one
Christmas yes they're so so good yeah a
little Ingham but I've had meatballs
from all different I mean this is before
I went vegan but it doesn't matter you
know I I've eaten them they're delicious
and they're they taste specific to
Swedish meatballs so what you're saying
is had a white assist oh my god well no
no no let me let me finish like I I'm
saying I I had meatballs from all across
the world I've been you're all across
Europe I've you know I've eaten
meatballs I I like meatballs spaghetti
meatballs my favorite go-to meals
they're definitely Swedish they are
they're very very slightest you sir are
a white supremacist why is that what
they're saying cuz Guardian says anyone
criticizing this is far-right are you
kidding me what is truly Scandinavian
nothing airline terrifies add after
far-right criticism not just that they
have pulled the ad down but I love this
story from The Guardian why did they
pull it down so if you would like to be
historically accurate and criticized
this ad when they tried to claim that
Swedish meatballs were actually Turkish
as a based off of a rumor on Twitter oh
I just want to it you know look I'm a
non-violent person but if there was
anything that would make me want to like
Homer Simpson strangle a small child
I'm joking by the way I was gonna take
that out of context yeah but you know
Homer like strangles by of course yeah
it's when some random person on Twitter
is like did you
know that Brad Pitt is John Lithgow
Steph you and then everyone's like fact
and it lands on Wikipedia because some
dumb journalist season goes that's
interesting in than adds it to a story
in passing and then someone takes it
puts on Wikipedia and then it becomes
citation and then no one questions it
yeah and then Brad Pitt is John Luther
Scott he's not actually as a Family Guy
joke by the way no she's do is like he's
like it's not true but it sounds good
like it could be right yeah but that's
why I use it an example so you know let
us out okay
I mean let me let me read this story in
the other theory the Scandinavian
airline SAS has clarified an
advertisement intended to highlight the
role of travel immigration and cultural
diversity is forging the region's
identity after it was pilloried online
by far-right and nationalist groups okay
here's what I love about this is
ridiculous if an American criticizes the
historical inaccuracies inaccuracies
they call you a nationalist bro I got no
stake in Sweden man yeah I don't can you
why they ended in my wife is Swedish
well you do well no and you know what
here's the thing I I've been in Sweden
many times throughout the past few years
and they have so many traditions it
blows me away midsummer they that's one
of many they have all these different
songs that just tagging from all the
different like seriously any season they
got a cool song about it they got then
they sing it together it's like they're
like hey hey Adam give us let's sing one
of your you know American traditional
songs and I'm like whoa whoa whoa whoa
but you don't know the American
traditional songs sure yeah what what
are some so is wait hold on yeah go
ahead what you're putting me on the spot
yes I have where it's I was put on the
same way they're like hey like they just
we just be in the mood if for spacious
skies for amber waves of grain
can I ask you have you ever mountains
majesty have you ever sung that around a
dinner table yes with your family I was
I was in no you have not I'm going to
now let's do it we have dinner will will
create you were asked to sing
traditional Americans known as they
asked me they were you know wanted to
include me you know and I because I was
like they actually straight up have a
nap
still have it it's called schnapps visa
and it's literally an app that shows you
Ipoh like it's all these different you
know you pick look there's all the
different little traditional midst of
times yeah it's on there you know that
midsummer look at all these midsummer
songs stop I got start right now listen
alright so I want to try and give you
guys a little bit of context in case
you're missing where we're at the
airline makes its commercial it is the
whole commercial was like did you know
that this Swedish thing was actually
Greek did you know this Swedish thing
was actually German they were like all
of these things that they're claiming
were Scandinavian were actually from
other places and it was one of the
stupidest commercials ever yeah and and
it wasn't just the far-right criticizing
them they literally just had a movie
come out called midsummer is that not
only Swedish is that it's Scandinavian I
don't know I'm not sure if it's in the
area this is my favorite part we are no
better than the Vikings oh no no no you
do not get to do that okay the Vikings
literally burn cities to the ground and
kidnapped the women and brought them
home you're a bunch of soy boy whiny
babies who are pretending like you never
invent anything because you're terrified
listen
Sweden has semla some like this as it
was I'm saying it right right similar
sounds right I don't know
fetish dogging it is it is it means Fat
Tuesday
okay Fat Tuesday it's also very European
but in a lot of these places semla is
very specific as far as I know to Sweden
because basically it's like sweetbreads
with like cardamom and they they cut it
open and put whipped cream and then put
whipped cream on and then bun back on
top oh there's that that comedian Kevin
Hart yes Kevin Hart now in in money with
Eastern Europe they put like it's very
similar but they put like blueberry jam
in it yeah so sweet and it's it's insane
that they've become obsessed with
arguing their own culture doesn't exist
anymore man thank you so much culture
it's good didn't-didn't Justin Trudeau
say something like that where he was
like there is no Canadian culture it's
like dude we literally make fun of the
way you talk right you have cheat you
have gravy on your french fries yeah
like we stereotype your silly culture
mm-hmm you know and we have like maple
maple that we make jokes did you know
that there was what at one point
Canada has a strategic
maple Reserve seriously and some people
like robbed it and it was like the great
maple heist of like 2013 or something I
think they had a tender tender driver
yeah the Canadian but could you imagine
like dudes wearing like imagine like you
know in Fast and the Furious and how
they're all wearing like you know I
don't know secret agent clothes or maybe
maybe a mission Impossibles a better
example and they're like dropping down
from the from the events there's like a
Laser grid and then they like hook a
tube up to a big gigantic Mrs
Butterworth I spin it out sucking out
Canada's maple syrup what is it
and Justin Trudeau had the nerve to say
there's no Canadian culture that's a lot
of culture that I don't I don't Yeah
right I don't if there's any country
that could have how many 3,000 gallons
of maple syrup
yeah growing up I was under the
impression that all maple syrup anywhere
came from Canada that's funny I know
it's not sure now but in America how
about that I thought that in America we
have a strategic oil reserve okay Canada
has strategic maple syrup reserve
literally stolen from a quote storage
facility
so they have a special place where they
keep you remember that scene in Breaking
Bad where they he steals the stuff from
the Train no I didn't see oh man I don't
know if you people see me breaking bad
but he Rob's a train base of it and it's
it's awesome what was seen that's what I
picture happening they're like oh we can
get the maple syrup from the train as
it's going 18 million dollars no that
was a month-long operation it took them
a while they did it over a month months
long months multiple can we get a movie
about this yes I want Dwayne the rock
Johnson I want Tom Cruise Vin Diesel I
want to take all and and and so that's
just on if you can still do it
Dolph Lundgren I want to take the
Expendables fast the furious Mission
Impossible all jammed and I want in
there and they steal that maple syrup
how did we forward you gotta have half
what you gotta have half the team as the
cops trying to stop the guy Oh figure
wait no all of them now Donald Trump's
the bad guy he's trying to protect
Canada's maple
and these like underground forces are
trying to see trying to build a pipeline
for the maple syrup you know what it's
actually really it's really interesting
that you guys bring this up because the
organization that was storing this syrup
this valuable priceless commodity
represents 77 percent of the global
maple syrup supply and if they have been
compared to a cartel whoa this is the
most valuable heist in Canadian history
wow that's pretty and you're gonna tell
me they got no culture did they get away
with it that's the same not I don't
think I always I don't know why I'm
always like oh well so so so here's that
here's the next part here's the next
part science race so this this stupid
post arguing that Swedish meatballs were
Turkish it's like somebody literally
dongs me so researchers for Sven Scott
dog blooded which I think it means
something like Daily News that means
researchers saw world the news about
meatballs fabricated this is Google
translated into English so mind you it's
a Swedish website okay but Swedish
meatballs are really Turkish the
official Swedish fact account sweden
dose esa2014 - food historian richard
tell strim the information is not
correct of course it's very serious he
says yes only like they love their
culture man they're so proud of their
song and then put bear in it's awesome I
wish I spoke Swedish so I can sing along
with these guys I know I know it's my
own fault
I could just learn it ah laziness
so I went to I'll admit it I went to
Bergen Norway okay and they were very
very proud of their whaling culture okay
even though it was considered like
whales yeah yeah kill whales and gosh
it's terrible and almost everyone else
in the world finds that bad yeah yet
they didn't care and I asked him I was
like we I was like well I as an American
we kind of don't like that you killed
whales yeah and they were like it's part
of our culture it's been we've been
doing it front of yours well you know
you don't understand and they wanted me
to eat it was like whale yeah but they
were doing it when they would go out and
like harvest it themselves now it's
probably a commercial hopper
where they're just killing killing
whales all the time I mean to support
the sub but the point is anyway yeah go
ahead if everyone thinks killing whales
is bad but Norway was like no it is good
we love killing whales and eating them
you don't understand they're willing to
defend a culture that everyone hates the
Sweden Swedish meatballs
who doesn't like Swedish meatballs I I
love them they're great it's food
it's meat in a ball with with with with
berries on it great IKEA actually has
some vegan Swedish meatballs in there
really good Sweden won't even defend
their own meatballs to save their own
culture that's what and then and then
sure enough got to Sweden the guardian
claims only the far right cares so this
is the only thing I want to talk about
sketchy if you literally are like I like
my country your far right that's like
that's like what we were talking about
the other day it's like if you if you
say anything about like the men versus
women thing it's like when you're just
like I know I'm just defending myself no
no no you're toxic masculine man right
exactly it's like instantly labelled
look at this guy vegan skateboarder
beanie wearing you know
hippy dippy and you and your fall right
I guess I am I do that's how absolutely
insane man
why why would anyone think it was a good
idea to make a commercial for your
country where you're like our country
sucks and if you deny it
you're far right it's like whoa I feel
like it doesn't sound like it's someone
from in Scandinavia that sounds like
someone from outside of the country
though I don't think so man I don't know
I don't get it because I know a lot of
them and they're all really awesome and
they have a really good culture and it's
awesome they yeah but I mean have you
dealt with the politics of Sweden I've
used I've dabbled I've seen it I've sat
and watched the news and they they were
they were they weren't denying forever
all of the problems they were having
yeah I see that there is a lot of
problems in the government there but you
know no I mean like with everything like
they're sitting here praising everything
that they have who's that that like the
Swedish Institute like this the the
commercial the airline so just the
airline you know they're sitting there
praising or often say praising but
they're criticizing where they base do
you know where they're based SAS Denmark
denmark-norway it's that marked Norway
and Sweden okay so not not just the one
okay but they make points about like you
know Denmark's danishes aren't actually
from Denmark they're actually from
Austria and what is the point of this so
go to Austria don't come here anymore I
think what here's the problem that
doesn't make sense
there was a study a long time ago and
they mapped Twitter okay
and they found clusters of different you
know networks all right digital
marketing overlapped with the resistance
which is like the anti-trump leftists
okay so for some reason I think it's
obvious I think it's the the people who
work in marketing are in big cities
surrounded by the same people in bubbles
you know and they thought this I don't
know who made this commercial or where
they are but they thought this is gonna
be a hit that everyone was gonna cheer
for them as they said our country never
made anything we're we're as bad as the
Vikings first of all the Vikings were
cool in a lot of ways and really really
bad in a lot of ways but to claim that
you would ever amount to the Vikings is
offensive to me and I'm not even Swedish
or Scandinavian I'm sorry Scandinavian
yeah because like well I am and I'm
upset you know I was trying to figure
out who made this
apparently there's a bomb threat called
in to the Copenhagen agency that made
this ad well it was a hoax but this is
earlier today they shut down the street
in front of the corporation so is it is
it in Copenhagen then that's their their
flagship I think it must have been an
empty one social media the cordon of the
area had been lifted no bomb was found
somebody was very unhappy about this ad
that's release you know that's been
happening the last time I flew to Sweden
there was a bomb threat and I had to I
mean it
oh dude in some ways you know Sweden has
more bombings than any other country not
at war I didn't know that Sweden
interesting exclude all of the countries
at war Sweden has more bombings than any
other country Wow I didn't know that and
that was when when I went there a few
years ago somebody threw a grenade on a
balcony little kid died tourist I think
it was British
man and so now it's only been getting
worse and I have a I have a friend who's
staying there and she said they can't
hide it anymore that's all they talk
about yeah so so here's the point the
crime in Sweden is still lower
in certain aspects then like many cities
in America okay
they have a lot smaller population yeah
much smaller but crime is it's it's
escalating like crazy did they have a
wave of lots of more people and it's
they're trying to figure it out what's
funny about this is that the ad agency
is in cope you said it's in Copenhagen
and they're actually tightening their
borders because of the crime pouring in
from Sweden and they make a commercial
like this they're completely oblivious
yeah it's kind of weird to me that this
would be coming out of Denmark when they
are literally strapping down their
border with you know those surrounding
countries cuz they are technically an
island they're connected I think to
Sweden by some small spit of land but
it's like a land bridge it's a really
long bridge you know it's it's it's so
weird how the Vikings their culture
devolved into it started with them
literally stealing women like going
other countries and taking them to now
them being like we've never done
anything of Merit so I'll tell you I'll
tell you what here's how are things
gonna happen well that's not that's not
the the society as a whole that's this
airline making it no way that's about
saying about digital marketing like the
people who are online this is the the
Swedish meatball oh you also said that
Twitter makes up 2 percent of the of
America ok of America so right what is
the percentage over there so like I said
I'm sure it's not memorable on Twitter
like fibers are the ones who write the
news media okay and so what you're
seeing is their bubble perspective which
they write down and spread among all the
people so what's gonna happen is the
Sweden Democrats which they call far
right you know masses or whatever I
don't know very much about I think
they're I don't know how long I was
going on but based on stuff like this
I'd be willing to bet they start gaining
more and more in the polls we're gonna
we already see it in Italy we're gonna
see it in France
there's gonna be a sweeping wave of
nationalism across all these countries
because of this because I'll tell you
what you do if you want to inspire
countries to be more international you
don't you don't smear and rag on the
people who are proud of it it makes them
angry and reactive yeah that's true what
a dumb commercial yeah it doesn't make
any sense I kind of want to watch it but
they take it down or what yeah look at
this
there's the funniest thing that hears it
it's like it's gone oh they had watch it
and it's gone due to a copyright claim
by Scandinavian Airlines
that's what it means that marks of
Norway Seaway people were taking it and
posting it and then they're like no no
no no yeah I don't know they pulled it
down oh oh right all right yep yeah I'm
sure other people took it too yeah I
can't find any copies on YouTube they're
pulling and pulling it down yeah man
that's that's crazy there was a a poll
was done in the UK asking why it was
that Labour was defeated so Rezound lee
like with the worst defeat in a hundred
years and they said it was weakness
indecisiveness and a lack of patriotism
those were the three key factors among
voters as to why they didn't vote for
Jeremy Corbyn okay when you see stuff
like this this is the opposite of
patriotism you you make a commercial
saying our country's terrible yeah
you're gonna get wiped out when people
see that and they're like how dare you
yeah people are proud of where they come
from yeah they totally are yeah thanks
for checking out this segment from the
Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
every Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8:00 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you